he is a freshly minted Super Bowl
champion Philadelphia Eagle man with 100
receiving yards in Super Bowl 52 in
Minnesota Corey Clement good to see you
sir
how are you Corey I'm doing good I can't
complain at all like you said Superbowl
champion I don't think it gets any
better than yeah I mean your smile is
it's perma-smile imagine right now
definitely cuz you are from the the
wonderful town of Glassboro New Jersey
correct you're from that's where I'm
riffing always so which is he would you
call that a suburb of Philadelphia how
far is it from Philly it's a good 20
minutes okay so I don't know if you
really want to consider it a suburb of
Philadelphia I think if you're still
over the bridge in Philly you can still
consider that too sober but right I'm
over to British Auto I don't think it's
over the bridge in New Jersey that's why
I'm still living I don't live in Philly
what do you mean I live over in Jersey
just a 20-minute drive every day to work
so how close you are used basically
you're not high guy I get asked this cuz
you're a rookie
wait are you living at home yeah no I'm
living I got my own apartment so no
things that going pretty well okay so
it's family still right around you yeah
my family most are in Philadelphia and
my brothers in New Jersey so that's
about it okay so let's start let's start
here with your last year one year ago at
this time you were fresh out of
Wisconsin right okay an outstanding Big
Ten program yes okay and you were
getting ready for the comma correct
that's what you were doing one year ago
today definitely thinking what what were
you thinking just got some great focus
for however many weeks of training it
was I guess it was six weeks you know
leading up into the the combine and just
had to you know put up some big numbers
but my Jeff I mean not my calm Monday
didn't really go as planned so what do
you what do you mean by that
so the the everybody knows the 40 I
didn't I didn't run my best 40 time that
day what did you run that day four six
eight nine incredible so you run four
six eight and what that that's what did
you what
supposed to run I mean all come on I
mean I mean all training like I was
running a four or five one four five too
easily so I guess when you got on a big
stage uh my must have blanked out for a
little bit tell me about it ya know the
same experiences every year you know you
got your place here you're good
you got your career and now I'm just
starting - oh thank you
you've got your place it's on a Super
Bowl podium you're in a parade which
we'll talk about Miss Ellie yeah so okay
so you run a four six eight there and
then you go to your pro day you run
better than that right that was a little
bit more hitting from us oh so what
happened draft what happened with the
draft with you um now it's projected to
go at least no late there early fourth
and if I did happen to slip it was you
know late fourth fifth at but uh you
know the day's kept going on and we
approached you know round six through
seven I'm like this is this is
unbelievable because you know I've been
hearing this leading up to it you know
you're gonna be off the boar at least
for frown and then I'm just saying with
my friends and family and when were you
in Jersey I was in Jersey alcohol and
glass were actually so it was kind of
disappointing I felt like I just you
know let everybody down because nobody
got a chance to hear my name call it so
I just won't ever get that day back
really and so your phone didn't ring I
imagine right when did your phone's
start ringing just start Riggin fifth
row team saying uh you know stay put and
we're gonna grab you here and there
which teams give me names um not named
the Eagles which ones I got the
Baltimore Ravens test bird Colts right a
few other teams and they were just
saying sit tight can't believe it's
still on the board I'm like well take me
off there so do me a favor but uh at the
same time know things worked out for a
reason so of course exact Corey Clement
here on the Rich Eisen show so when did
the Eagles call your agent or do they
they were uh they were actually the
first the first to jump there before the
draft they were saying you know now look
out for the phone but uh I said about
iPhone all day you did yeah so uh I
understand it's a business
you know the guys who really want to
call the shots that can call this to
head min upstairs so I just had to wait
my turn
well look the reason why I'm bringing
all this up excuse of a journey and I'm
leading up to a photograph that really
hit me we're leading up to that and then
look Brady still wears $1.99 on his
sleeve Maurice jones-drew Ward number 32
cuz all 32 teams passed on him yeah
right so these things are happen for
reason and you're you know that's gonna
burn inside you for quite some time Cory
but so when when did the Eagles say come
on in and how did you get a fixed up
Eagles they uh after the seventh round
they called immediately I'll talk to my
agent and I didn't know you got a chance
to pick where you want to go as a free
you know free agent yeah or whatever
that case was I said I get a chance to
pick I'll stay at home and I want to
play for the birds and grew up watching
them you know family everybody knows I
mean I materials just you know I can
remember so now get a chance to
opportunity to play for them know why
not I didn't think of any other team
right and so you've got a tat you've got
ink on your arm Super Bowl so you're a
Burt you have a Burt lift it up for the
route television I just peel it right
now so okay got the Eagle that's a eagle
on your right ear do the skin okay yeah
and then on your back left of your neck
you've got one Super Bowl fifty two such
just that's fresh yes fresh all these
are not even three days old
well you know what I don't know cuz I'm
I'm a free agent coming up this
September and I just don't know you know
several quick I know it is better get it
on the world I'm waiting for the
franchise tag you know I mean that's
true though you're right Le'Veon Bell I
want to set the market hope he does
I love that Cory Clement here on the
Rich Eisen show so when did you start
realizing you had a chance to
significantly add to the Eagles mix um
no before I even got there I realized
know who was on a roster you know I love
to compete
no that's why I went to Wisconsin
because they had James why they had
Melvin Gordon and the people asked me
why you want to go to such a crowded
back field and you know me I placed
myself wherever I can keep growing and
you know if I go to a place where I
think that uh now I have an opportunity
to make them better and compete this
Gosselaar gonna elevate my level so um
you know to have window Smallwood well
just time Sproles yes-man bluntly and
Ajay in the season yeah I mean there's
some some things get kind of mixed
around Oh what are they gonna do with me
I got questions up and down I just said
we're just gonna keep running so
whatever they choose to do with me at
the end of the day I have no controller
okay so then let's get to Super Bowl 50
- let's do it let's do it you wake up
that day you think what I have so many
mixed feelings I didn't know how to I
didn't know how to think it was one of
those morning's where I felt I'm real
I'm like let me go back to sleep for a
little bit I couldn't I woke up at 6:15
I can remember it like it was nothing
laid there for a good hour and a half I
really got myself together and just said
well today is the Super Bowl like
whoever things to know I'll be saying
that when that day I thought it'd take
me at least five or ten more years in
the league to you know get to that point
but the first year it was pretty cool
man just know watching everybody grow
and we're at this point now it was a
blessing so you get to the stadium no
but did you think this is my day this is
my damn oh for sure um you know you
gotta have confidence rolling into any
game I tell myself knows Saturday nights
as I'm driving it to the hotel now
you're gonna have a big day just you
know have fun play your heart out and
whatever else after that you know you
can't control it because if you know you
gave it your all that's you can't really
question anything else so pray hard
study hard that was a result not Cory
Clement here in the Rich Eisen show I
know the ball sometimes finds you and
it's your day and things of that nature
okay you've been you played dozens
hundreds of games did you was their game
plan when it was installed in the
conversation you're watching film with
the Patriots defense it said
is it dawn on you slowly but surely that
I have a roll significant role in Super
Bowl 50 - that's cooking here oh yeah
definitely
they uh they showed me the the play
chart you know mine was heavy that week
so I was like this is gonna be my date
my opportunity goes up so I'm balanced
and make a big play here and there I saw
a Corey grant do what he did I'm playing
for the Jacksonville Jaguars and the
game he had against him and I feel like
we have you know we kind of matched the
same intensity style you know play with
that we have and they were able to get
around those linebackers and I was like
if I'm able to be utilized in that area
then we should have a great day out
there and then you made that big first
play yeah then I got that underneath
your belt yeah sure the score but I just
just getting everything out the way but
you know everything after that game it
was it was all worth it it's interesting
that you say you should have scored a
touchdown there many people in New
England including that guy over there
who thinks you did not score a touchdown
in that game Cory Clement what do you
say to people like that I called it
based on how the rule was appropriated
all season long with all due respect did
you think that that was not a touchdown
that was if you if you if you look at
the left yes yes leaked slowly grazed
the ground that's the the final foot I
need it but the bobble
stayed here in the ball did it move ball
didn't move because I heard the ref
talking about it after I got a chance to
watch the sound effect yeah and why it
wasn't ruled to drop because the ball
did move but I mean my hands move but
the ball still staying in the same place
hands move Boston so possession was
still you know what they say ball don't
lie don't lie
I want to take a break and come back and
talk about the the place sheet yeah
Philly Philly you were the one who
flipped it to tray Burton and throws it
to Nick Foles the moment when you knew
that once was done down for the season
so much to talk about and then again
that that photograph that you tweeted
out in 2012 I want to hit on that
because I think it just brings
everything full circle for you Cory
Clement here on the Rich Eisen show and
then your honor are you out here for the
NBA all-star yeah oh we can I said we'll
talk about that and you know your likes
and dislikes on the front as well before
Marv Albert joins us here and he's
calling the game that's what's coming up
next on the Rich Eisen show do you want
to talk to you right now about Sleep
Number you know you get into Sleep
Number bed right do you hear about that
well all NFL players are getting Sleep
Number if you're lying I'm not it's
coming when you up this this summer it's
coming
I'm telling you Sleep Number let me
break news to you Sleep Number in the
NFL and our partners and every single
NFL player is getting a voucher for a
Sleep Number bet they're one of the
Eagles and the NFL wants to know what
your sleep IQ is and how you sleep
throughout the night you play I am not
[Music]
about to get one sir I need one it's
you're getting it you're getting it
you're gonna find out what you're
sleeping my sleep number is 60 do you
like the the bed firm or song a little
bit are you gonna find out what your
Sleep Number is what your sleep IQ
number is gonna be you're gonna love it
Corey you're gonna love it 9 out of 10
owners recommend a Sleep Number bed I'm
one of them Corey Clements about to be
one of them I'm not playing you're gonna
get it coming in a comment during the
ultimate Sleep Number event right now
save 50% on an ultimate limited edition
bed plus queen mattresses started only
$6.99 ninety-nine there's over 500
stores nationwide find out the one
nearest you in Glassboro New Jersey at
Sleep Number calm / eyes
[Music]
all right well we're induced to
television only break it just dawned
upon me Cory Clement who your friend is
over there introduce him go ahead we
have mr. Dario guma wale in the building
reskins running back how you doing
brother
Redskins running back he's sitting on
the tiny man couch that uh that uh is
called by Aisha Tyler Gaga was running
back me you know I just build it just
realize this you guys punked Michigan on
occasion correct did you beat Michigan
or you - well we beat a mister now this
year now like well we I think we won the
game
did we win the games or you yeah your
seat yeah yeah but you scored yeah you
are you're a beast
that guy's a beast over there here's a
visa over there we all overlooked was
constant was constant running backs
always get overlooked oh no idea I mean
I mean I mean James why he put his he
put us on a mess I don't know why they
keep dating in the in the era that we're
here today but I mean he's I don't know
we come from a program meshes gritty I
don't know this
that's just our little slang we use it's
just great great over there I will talk
about this how you want how does a kid
from New Jersey wound up in Wisconsin
okay I'll hit that
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Oh stats yeah we don't do uh next-gen
stats see we do old gents tell story
Clement yeah so Philadelphia Eagles
running back Corey Clement here on the
Rich Eisen show the old gent stat is
brought to you by our friends at Farmers
Insurance as conditions on the field
change so can your insurance needs
please talk to a farmers agent today so
you can assess whether your policy is
game ready find an agent at farmers
dot-com Cory you had 100 yards receiving
on the dot insuperable that is the
fourth most receiving yards by a rookie
in Super Bowl history behind Torry Holt
Chris Matthews if you recall he was that
tall receiver that almost beat you in
the Super Bowl crazy juggling Oh
everybody is crazy juggling tack catches
against the Patriots in the Super Bowl
parent days and Chris Collinsworth who
called Cory Clements 100 yards receiving
and the third most receiving yards by a
running back in Super Bowl history do
you know who the other two are Cory
Clement Roger Craig is the old school
one and you mentioned today's what the
other one woody was conscious all over
how much did he have on that see now now
you're asking me that 114 is that what
he had in 14 catches what's your old gen
stat here in the Rich Eisen show for
clip okay so you show up as you
mentioned in the last segment that your
your play sheet is as full as you call
it right so much larger than a normal
regular season game yeah that makes
sense too because are you where how many
regular-season yards you had a more
receiving yards in the postseason you
had 139 do you know how much you had in
your entire regular season 123 and I had
how many hundred and thirty nine okay
and so you see your play sheet is like
that was Philly Philly on the place
sheet was actually gonna play sheet for
two weeks
what do you mean from we actually had it
in for the Vikings but we didn't need to
use it so a good thing we didn't have to
we say to put it in the back pocket for
the last game and why not you know of
course but but why not how about do it
on fourth down at the end of the first
half it's they're turning down three
you're gonna go for this we've seen on
NFL Films how it all went down where
fold suggests it Coach Peters no he did
they're from the dome did not no no I
was just chillin in a huddle and then
what happened I thought it was coach
Peterson's ruling like two to go for it
and uh but clearly I saw Nick just say
Philly Philly everybody had confidence
in Philly Philly we just had to run it
at the right time well how many times
did you practice it Oh grand total times
matter of probably eight and that was
no.28 time it was we didn't need to mess
with it anymore the last time we ran it
was in the Gophers practice facility and
left it at the throughout the week yeah
so it wasn't like a walkthrough in a
hotel ballroom or something no it was
the last time we did it was actually
game like game read like full speed in
practice and that was it but it all
starts with you getting the direct snap
Cory I'm not was hoping Kelsey than high
snap it and it all turned into some
crazy stuff I was I thought that was
gonna happen I thought it so I initially
I looked up just to make sure it wasn't
a high snap and then I brought my eyes
back down a little bit and got busy
after that then you flip it to trade
Burton yeah and then what happened I
think I put my hands up in the end zone
I only think I watched the rest of the
play I was just so confident I was
waiting for the crowds noise mm-hmm
hopefully it was our crowd
yeah right so I'll turn around and Nick
had the ball so that was pretty cool
that's pretty cool we got the Philly
Philly go and the rest is history
yeah was the formation legal it was
legal I believe to make it legal I think
Nick had to be outside of lane so good
thing he was where he was at at the
right time New England well didn't
pereira same receiver at the top of the
screen was two yards but the refs the
refs
gave the thumbs about time at the
discretionary call
see it's tough for people to swallow I
think it's to me it still worked so oh
no he was wide open amazing play well it
seems like you were called Cory Clement
for an illegal formation during the
parade what what what happened during
the parade I have no idea here here are
you just as you can see in a video I'm
just standing on my phone
mm-hmm what's going on on Twitter mm-hmm
then I look up yeah and I thought it was
a joke I'm like what is this what do you
what and police come up to you yeah I'm
like guys you gonna help me and they
took they thought that you would jump to
the fanswers yeah I'm like what are you
doing I'm clearly with the team here and
then I shrugged my shoulders like stupid
just trying to do their job I understand
but they could have asked me first or
even the team if not come with me why
were you off the bus at all we were all
off the bus I saw that I think you were
freaking out law enforcement by
constantly getting off the bus we uh we
just we just wanted to share with them
we didn't want to be so far away and on
a bus that was already cold so why not
just walk and have all the cold it smack
you in the face then and then of all the
stories you know just Nick Foles the
same what he said after the game about
how failure we asked what the what the
message is that failure sometimes can be
used or should be used all the time
actually as a betterment of oneself and
how in this day and age of social media
that we just glorify everything that we
know how did that hit you um I think it
definitely hit home because like I said
everybody's had some trials and
tribulations in their life you know
failure also no shape shoot in a way
that you really don't even see it
sometimes until you actually face what
reality um like I said my my journey
started off with a sense of failure
because I didn't I didn't get the number
one task which was to get drafted so
that was a failure on my side but at the
same time it made me grow as the season
window I don't know how to not take
anything for granted so when I
opportunities presented sees it and then
I saw on Twitter day at night of the
game
think Daffy the game a photograph of you
from 2012 that you tweeted out and
you're standing in front of what looked
like to be the Nova Care Center that
round of the press the press area and
there it is taken on may 16 2012 how old
were you in this photograph
I guess 7,000 so here we at six years
ago now so you're 17 or 18 years old
since you haven't had your birthday yet
this year and it says one day someday
one day someday it's funny how things
work out right I just one day we were on
the field I don't know why we had a
field trip that day I didn't know you
had field trips in high school still but
when I when I set up there I really
wanted to make a statement saying I had
so many people saying you're not gonna
do this you're not gonna do that and
then that day really really uh I was
actually upset that day after I left
because people just doubted my dreams
left and right because I didn't get any
Division one school offers yet but um I
just put that there just to stamp it and
look back on it like today and there's a
see how far I've come now and obviously
you've got so far to go yeah Corey
Clement but that said yeah 100 yards in
the Superbowl to bring the trophy to
your team to that town to have that
parade yeah the one day some day kid
would say what to that like I said I
keep faith how you keep pushing you know
even when you're faced with no
negativity in your life there's always
you know there's still always light at
the end of that tunnel that you can no
still search so um I found mine and now
I can just keep running with it and so
you're here for embiid in the Sixers oh
yeah I'm here for the whole weekend I'm
here I'm here to watch them good old
basketball okay yeah I'll never really
get a chance to watch it during the
season but now it's the time to actually
own one and you know watch a different
sport for a little bit okay yeah which
one would you be a better at dunk
contest or three-point shooting what you
think you're looking at your buddy okay
alright I got a little time I got a
little three I'm not a kid don't you
can't dunk I can touch room but I
hey I really get the Cory Cory enjoy the
weekend enjoy being a Super Bowl
champion hopefully there's a beginning
of a friendship you and me in the show
and everything definitely do this let's
do it big tent big tent sticking
together
yes we can congratulations thank you on
everything going on with you and your
career and again these rookie seasons
are so freaking long they're long and
yours is now in the books and in the
best way possible so congratulations
you've got Cory Clement here on the rich
odds and she'll follow him on Twitter at
Cory Clement underscore six the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience